how's the gum raise my name is welcome
back to finites of phrase to part
[ __ ] me I would add no last episode we
struggled I struggle with night for it's
hard it's [ __ ] hard ok hey Jesus
Christ we haven't even started alright
bullet pardon me while I go through this
[ __ ] again
I don't know if that just anything if I
blink him here like this it works if I
blink them over there why wouldn't I
blink of her here right am i right am i
right am i right away my rolling breast
and mereta my wrong go away [ __ ] me
Balloon Boy already it's 1:00 a.m. wake
up senpai suck my ass we'll be together
it's not even 1 a.m. and so much [ __ ]
has happened that is why I'm mad
whatever give me a [ __ ] break
great - [ __ ] chicken [ __ ] here
Jessica I'm so [ __ ] focused when I'm
playing this prize yeah it's like you
play for so long - so it's kind of like
I can't talk all the time when I play
this well I'll just be sitting like oh
that's pretty cool I guess
come on I knew you were coming come on I
lost me like it's like a split second
you lose it the chicken [ __ ] doesn't
make sounds chicken the chicken [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] sneaky [ __ ] [ __ ] I
think I ever [ __ ] swear so much as I
play this game I should play this game
with electric shock challenge I'd be
like Lehr little nightmare now like how
those crumbled papers look like
handicapped sonic squirrels or some
shadow 3 amorous
Jesus guys halfway there I guess no
we're not it's not a talk [ __ ] he's here
what did he call come on he was coming
when I was wearing a mask that's
[ __ ]
there's nothing I can do about that look
look at my battery how the [ __ ] did that
happen
apparently I think it drains your
battery even if you hold it down when
it's not working
come on I flashed him you [ __ ] saw me
flash him don't don't [ __ ] me I
[ __ ] flashed him my patience right
now mmm that's sexual I'm so sorry I
didn't realize
I'm so [ __ ] concentrated like I was
this concentrated in school I would have
[ __ ] ace everything this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] wait wait ricardio I'm keeping my
eye on you [ __ ] I'm doing [ __ ]
fabulous all right and I'm not gonna
lose this one does that mean he's here
or [ __ ] I don't know they switch
places and [ __ ] now I don't [ __ ] know
how to deal with that oh my god the
adrenaline of my anus is just crawling
up like a little worm I can't this
[ __ ] game man
it makes me go to 5:00 a.m. as leaves
I'll then all happy I'll make some
[ __ ] progress in this [ __ ]
miserable life I have I'm gonna flash
you so [ __ ] hard that your [ __ ]
dick fell falls off not great chicken
[ __ ] is here now see see no no no no I
did not put on the [ __ ] mask I did
not act on the [ __ ] mask what the
[ __ ] was that [ __ ] [ __ ] ass leaking
[ __ ] [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] what was that I was gonna
flash and then I pulled the mic down as
a little no it's fine this is me when
it's fine this is me when it's [ __ ]
fine
can't you see how [ __ ] fine I am I've
no idea what the [ __ ] going on where
the [ __ ] is everyone let's find more
ways to [ __ ] with me guys just find more
ways I'm so eager what am I supposed to
do with you you just [ __ ] come out of
nowhere you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ] as
[ __ ] [ __ ] suck my ass suck my
ass every day every day suck my ass suck
my ass
oh my god so [ __ ] scary so [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass-licking
[ __ ] [ __ ] as [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright I took a little break sorry and
we're gonna [ __ ] take okay time put
it this way breasts I want you to follow
my lip what I'm doing shut up you
[ __ ] ass licking the [ __ ]
all right do like this do like this and
then follow follow and say what I say we
shall fist the anus of the animatronics
brofist wait oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] alright if we don't if we
don't complete on this one I will
attempt to suck my own ass it's a lot at
stake here oh my god this [ __ ] ass
licking [ __ ] game
I don't think I've ever swore this
[ __ ] much in my entire [ __ ] life
I'm so focused - I'm ginger sorry
where the [ __ ] did he come from what the
ass licking what the [ __ ] did you see
that
see some of them will just be like lose
develop oq visible oh go away you are
away I didn't say you are guess if
you're away get it it's [ __ ] funny
that way 3 a.m. well wait halfway the
wait wait wait what's the problem here
buddy what's the problem buddy did I
just get [ __ ] I think I just got
[ __ ] 7 a.m. waking up in the morning
gotta be fresh gotta go downstairs gotta
have my bowl gotta have my cereal seeing
everything if time is ticking I am dead
now [ __ ] me gotta get down to there buzz
I think my problem is that I don't use
the mask enough
maybe I need to [ __ ] a bit more get a
[ __ ] job get a job get a job and suck
my ass so if I just put it on the mask
eat fast enough I'm fine it's that
[ __ ] it's that all I had to do all
this [ __ ] time that's all I had to do
all this [ __ ] time are you [ __ ]
kidding me I would have been done with
this [ __ ] hours ago
like if someone told me you don't wear
the mask when the chicken and never
comes but that's exactly what I need to
do so thanks for the tips I guess I'm
glad I listened to you guys and take
your feedback [ __ ] carry this it's
not it's just not fair I read up some
tips and yes it seems like you just have
to be really fast putting the mask on so
I'm just gonna start being really
careful at night okay I was pretty
[ __ ] fast that if that doesn't work
I'll lose face in [ __ ] humanity how
about that that was pretty [ __ ] fast
they're safe they donäôt [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
off I ate all of yo god I hate everyone
for I am what you got all about that if
that I got a my yelling a lot cuz I
can't [ __ ] tell my anus is ticked to
shite [ __ ] singing to me tonight oh
sorry this is my diarrhea I was pretty
[ __ ] pass
[ __ ] me I wasn't fast enough
suck my ass then see if I give a [ __ ]
sucking ass licking [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] [ __ ]
person hate hate and anger ah baby I'm
gonna do it this time I have it in my
ass I have it in my ass
it's not even [ __ ] hard once you know
how to [ __ ] come on
well now I pull down I swear to god I
[ __ ] pulled I pulled my penis to
[ __ ] space oh my god that is the
biggest [ __ ] I ever [ __ ] sucked
my ass yeah this game will be the end of
me I'm doing everything perfect and then
it [ __ ] you it's five the [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass licking am suck my ass
senpai suck my brother is ready
[ __ ] lookin out I swear to God
if you [ __ ] away I will [ __ ] I pull down
I don't want to [ __ ] anymore